Speaker 1: of the questions for like a year,
I guess, but particularly in the last three
to four months, is what is happening at the
Justice Department under the stewardship of
Attorney General Merrick Garland.
Why is there not investigation, criminal investigation
going on of at least some of the things that
former President Donald Trump did?
We have now received confirmation from the
Attorney General, Merrick Garland, that the
Justice Department indeed received information
about the classified records found among the
documents recovered from Trump's Mar a Lago
and that the Justice Department is looking
into it now.
This colloquially means that they are investigating.
Whether this would technically be called an
open criminal investigation is a question
mark.
NPR reporting Attorney General Merrick Garland
said the Justice Department is aware that
classified material has been found on Trump's
Mar a Lago property, but didn't explicitly
confirm a federal probe is underway.
Let's take a look at the video clip.
This is during a press conference.
The audio is not great, but I think we will
be able to make out what's being said.
Speaker 5: Questions.
Last week, the National Archives revealed
that it found classified information in 15
boxes of documents stored at Mar a Lago.
Is the Justice Department investigating to
determine how the how that classified information
out there and who might have access?
So as as the archivist said in a letter that
was sent to the Congress, the National Archives
has informed the Justice Department of this
and communicated with it, and we will do what
we always do under these circumstances.
Look at the facts and law and take it from
there.
Speaker 1: So, you know, he's using very careful
language, he says.
We have received the information and we are
going to do what we always do.
We're going to look at the facts and we're
going to look at the law now.
I think he's being very careful here.
He is not saying we have opened a federal
investigation because that's very specific
and formal language.
He is saying we are investigating and at this
point, is this merely a semantic question?
It may be because I see no interest whatsoever
in seriously looking at the possibility of
indicting Donald Trump.
I mean, I just I just don't see it.
So the fact that he's informally saying there's
an investigation without calling it a federal
probe, I think is not ultimately going to
be super meaningful.
Now, of course, at this point, there would
be a real question for all the people who
back in 2016 said, I'm not voting for Hillary,
I'm voting for Trump because Hillary can't
be trusted with sensitive information.
Hillary can't be trusted with classified information
or emails, the private email server, et cetera,
et cetera.
Those people should now be saying, Wow, if
those were my concerns with Hillary, I never
should have voted for Donald Trump.
But if you actually go and talk to them, the
vast majority will just excuse away this behavior
and say it's not really that bad or Trump
was justified in doing it, or it's a witch
hunt or the claims are untrue or whatever
the case may be.
I've even seen online some conservative.
I don't have a really conservative, some Trumpian
reactionaries saying Trump did everything
right here.
Trump's own people found the classified documents
and called the National Archives and said,
Hey, guys, we've got this stuff.
You should come and get it really quickly.
There is no evidence that that's what took
place, right?
The narrative they want to create is Trump
had no idea about these documents, and Trump
staff found them and immediately of their
own volition called the National Archives
and said, Come and get the documents.
Of course, there is no evidence that that
is the story, but at the end of the day, I
don't believe Merrick Garland has any interest
in indicting a former president, and the fact
that they are generally investigating without
confirming an open federal probe is a distinction.
But I don't think it will make a functional
difference in terms of what we are to expect.
If you think Garland might have an appetite
for indicting Trump, let me know.
I've seen no evidence to suggest that that's
the case.